you
we are rocking the streamys right now
look at you looking fashion elite
wonderful but I got what is this Bevers
on my eyes don't even know what I her
are you keeping them up in what they
work a new shirt actually I can't quote
them too much it don't get stuff but I'm
having a good time awaiting your steady
show name oh I'm having a great time
I'll run around going oh you owe you I
know your video so it's really fun
ah
charo my char when I go way back no we
don't know what I still think that's
going to be interesting I don't know I'm
interested to see everybody we have
another iced vanilla iced over privilege
boy very cute Soulja Boy as well I like
to think I'm the kind of girl so
it was amazing it was amazing freaking
awesome it's awesome fun it was fun it
was so fun it was fun it was all right
wasn't a big deal you guys are nominated
for a lot of stuff tonight actors best
actress award
here we deserve it keeps to be
recognized one best uh di me why do I
how to yes for master class so I'm
really really proud of and we were
nominated for a bunch of choreography
things but then we're excited just to
all be here especially with all of you
from the community on YouTube and
elsewhere to celebrate digital media I
feel like every everything I've worked
on is an adventure to discover something
about myself or the people around me
that I get to work with and feel very
lucky to have different groups of super
creative people that I get to
collaborate with it's kind of nice to
have a couple wins in the bucket you
know it's exciting to have potentially
more yeah so to be you should be a good
time so which means you already have in
here though we have writings I one for
writing and then we have interactive
so basically put two on the creative
side which is nice and then we get to
see if we're going to work for actress
performance cast and comedy any industry
that you've been a part of for long
enough it becomes almost incestuous you
work with everyone and you become
friends with everyone and just feels
almost like I get together almost like a
reunion of sorts so I'm excited to see
almost all of my old friends and keep